is MGM starting to approach a few actors
regarding the Stargate movie are they
trying to find their cast welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
now about six months ago I told you that
actually Robert Carlisle who used to be
on Stargate Universe has been approached
about potentially appearing in a
Stargate movie TV series something they
apparently put feelers out to his agents
to find out whether he might or might
not be interested now we don't actually
know what the result of that
conversation was but it was evidence
that Amazon and MGM were starting to
think about who they might like to
appear in this series now why are they
looking at actors at this point well
it's very difficult to decide on
development of the series unless you
know who's going to appear in it now for
example we are pretty confident that
Amanda Tapping and Michael Shanks have
both been approached and maybe even
agreed already to appear in the movie in
series or at very least verbally agreed
if they were seriously looking at Robert
Carlisle that would suggest very
strongly that star Target Universe and
the Destiny was somehow going to be
involved in those plans or at very least
Mark Fergus penguin in a park or whoever
is going to be producing this TV series
was wondering where this Target Universe
could be involved and they needed to
approach one or two of the actors from
that franchise to find out whether it
was even possible at the end of the day
if Robert Carlisle says no I'm not doing
it or David blue does etc then the whole
idea of Stargate Universe being involved
in this kind of false flap before it
even starts
but now that we think we're going to be
getting an announcement in the middle of
June for the new Stargate franchise I've
started to hear loads of other rumors
about other actors one in particular
I've now heard several times but let's
start with a ridiculous rumor that I
actually think could possibly be true
but I'm hoping isn't
James Spader currently is appearing in
The Blacklist
honestly the suspense
oh I hate needles I'm going okay I
really don't need to stay for this part
all of the smacking and the whacking
are you okay what is it
oh okay
if there's nothing else I can do for you
I think I'll go explore it is a very
successful actor he obviously appeared
in the original Stargate movie as Daniel
Jackson I heard very very recently that
there is a possibility that Amazon and
MGM would quite like him to return to
the new franchise now I've already told
you that Michael Shanks has been
approached so how would that work well
according to this Source James Spader
would return but he would not be playing
Daniel Jackson he would be playing an
older character a different person
they've sort of done this with reboots
before and there is also the argument
that can sort of say well the original
Stargate movie in the Stargate series
kind of existed in different universes
so that's why we have different actors
in the series that's why a lot of the
things that the gold ruled were
different Etc so why not bring a big
actor like James Spader through it would
excite the fans we'd love it now I doubt
this is true I'm I very much doubt it
but what I say it's 100 not true would I
say that Amazon would never do it no
it's 100 sort of thing Amazon would do
but let's have a look and let's wait and
see at the end of the day his series The
Blacklist is coming to an end soon he
maybe is free so let's see Joshua orpin
played Superman in the Titan series
recently his name has come up once or
twice now I'm going to put this as a
maybes he's quite a young up and coming
actor he wouldn't be particularly
expensive to get in the role he's not
bad you could see him as a military a
young military sort of soldier you know
if they're bringing in a new sg1 team or
something and he's going to be sort of
like a newbie in the SGC
his name has been batted around a few
times
I'm not really bothered either way in
Star Trek Voyager Ethan Phillips played
neelix he's one of those actors that
pops up in all sorts of things he's most
recently been in Avenue five he's he's
unlikable quite comedic actor
I've heard the rumor two or three times
now that MGM would quite like him to
appear in the new Stargate franchise
potentially as a sort of a background a
scientist sort of character I completely
again could see this happening I'm not
really bothered either way though if I'm
100 honest a couple of the answers
though that I've heard named most often
and I've heard these both named now
several times from different sources and
it would seem that showrooms would be
interested in potentially building the
new show around are two actors Aaron
kellyman and Santiago Cabrera now
Erin kellyman was most recently in the
willow series and she played Jade
Claymore she also was in the Falcon
Winter Soldier she's quite an
up-and-coming actress she's that one
with the red curly hair you'd know when
you see it
I actually think this is quite an
interesting character again she'd be
quite young she would have to be sort of
like new to the SGC I should imagine
them depending on whether there is still
a military and um potentially a
cooperation between civilian
organizations with a new Stargate
project basically on whether it's
announced that the whole world knows
about the Stargate or not would be
interesting so whether she's military or
not we'd have to see she could
definitely handle herself she was pretty
good in the willow with the swords and
everything so you know when it comes to
the swords fights and everything she was
also pretty good in the Winter Soldier
actually in the same respect so she
could definitely do a lot of the acting
fight scenes and things she's a pretty
good actress I could see this lady
coming into this and actually being a
very popular character
Santiago Cabrera is the one that I'm
most interested in now this guy was in
the first two seasons of Picard and
playing Captain Rios now he's pretty
much the only thing that was any good in
the first two seasons of Picard he's the
only thing in either series that I
particularly consistently enjoyed he's
one of those actors that I just like him
and everything he does I first came
across him years ago he played a
character in Merlin which is a BBC show
over here
um he was also in Heroes he played the
artist who was painting the future and
stuff in the first the good season of
Heroes you remember that the good one
before then wandered off into the
nonsense it became
um so he's a actor that's been around
for quite a while he has just obviously
finished up a card he doesn't have any
major big projects coming up he's doing
like some sort of podcasting and
something else
so he would seem to be available
I've heard his name four or five times
now over the last six months or so
um I didn't really think much of it
initially because you know we were so
far away from a new series it seemed odd
to have an actor in mind of this level
sort of thing
but the name seems to be consistently
brought back up again so if he's
available if he wants to do it he would
seem to be a character that could sort
of take on that Richard Dean Anderson
sort of role the slightly older Soldier
he definitely has a wide range of acting
so he can do a little bit of the humor
he can do sort of like some of those
sarcastic little whips that Richard
Anderson was so brilliant at and to be
honest if you think about him in
Stargate
I can kind of see him fitting it's it's
the actor that I think most out of all
the names I've mentioned previous he's
the one that goes for me yeah I can see
him there if any of these rumors are
true I'm hoping the one about Santiago
Cabrera is the one that's actually true
because he could be great but guys get
into the comments tell me what you think
about any of these actors I've mentioned
does any of them think that yes they
would 100 fit within the Stargate
franchise could they very easily become
part of the Stargate family or actually
you don't like them you don't want them
anywhere near Stargate thank you very
much but who else would you like if not
these guys I'd love to know please get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you can go over to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]